das hier ist der neue chicken Big Mac
und den werde ich jetzt für euch testen
der ist zwar neu aber in Deutschland
gibt's glaube ich erstmal nicht ich bin
nämlich gerade in Holland aber ich
musste es einfach testen wir sind extra
rausgefahren guckt euch das mal an zwei
chicken pieces anstelle von den Buletten
und es kann eigentlich nur geil sein
probieren wir
die Chicken Patties schmecken genau wie
McNuggets und ich glaube das ist alles
was ich sagen muss mit der Big Mac Soße
ist das auf jeden Fall ein Big Mac aber
irgendwie ein bisschen zu trocken durch
die Panade ich glaube ich würde mich
immer für den klassischen Big Mac